[Music]
now first
afghans desperate to escape taliban rule
have been trying to board evacuation
flights out of the country and videos of
the chaotic scenes have been seen across
the world
joe biden now insists this was always
the plan but how will the public see it
to discuss i'm joined by our deputy
editor freddie gray who writes this
week's politics column on the issue and
by ben page ceo of polling from ipsos
murray
freddie ben thank you for joining us
today on spectate tv and freddie first
you say biden has learnt a valuable
lesson from donald trump can you explain
well i i think that obviously biden is
getting a lot of political flack about
his decision to withdraw from
afghanistan and his insistence that it
was the right thing
to do and i think uh that the immediate
polls
uh i'm sure ben who's about to join us
will tell us a bit more about that but i
think the immediate polls show that
there's a slight decline in his job
approval rating
but i think what biden has understood is
that
in
triggering the sort of media apoplexy
the kind of global media anger that he
has
uh in the last few days you can quite
often win over a lot of voters and i
don't want to get involved in the the
kind of morality of afghanistan and
those issues i want to just talk about
in terms of what biden's thinking
politically
uh i think that a lot of voters will be
thinking
the pompous journalist the sort of the
elite ruling class
that we don't like and it's not just
trumpist voters that think like that
it's it's a broad swathe of american
voters they'll be thinking if they're so
angry about what biden's doing
and we generally support the idea of
withdrawing from afghanistan which they
do
uh i think it could end up being a net
positive
for joe biden
ben do you think he could be a net
positive how are those polling numbers
looking for him well his his yeah his
his overall support levels dropped to
the lowest point in his presidency but
it's only down seven points from 53 to
46 approval so he's still doing rather
better than donald trump did at any
point but it's fair to say that his
ratings on handling the war are now the
lowest of any president um during the
last 20 years uh but overall i think in
in one sense i agree with freddie
because the america for
most americans afghanistan is a far away
place about which they know very little
indeed and the majority of americans say
that they had to cut leave at some point
61 percent say that they we should that
they were right to proceed with the
withdrawal on the schedule that had been
announced
and although three-quarters want them to
intervene in in humanitarian terms and
secure the airport and do all the things
that they're now doing um
only around half actually want to see
any sort of major military involvement
there again so i mean the american
public are a bit mixed but the balance
of opinion is that he's done the right
thing
so provided there aren't too many
casualties and there isn't another 911.
uh he's probably got away with it
and freddie when joe biden uh spoke for
the first time publicly since the
situation in afghanistan descended as it
did uh you saw a pitch that was very
much focused on the domestic audience it
appalled many in the international
community um but do you think ultimately
the white house is just not particularly
bothered what many of biden's normal
allies think he took a long time to
speak for example to your other leaders
i think that's true i mean certainly
there were a lot of things biden's got
wrong i mean it took him ages to
speak uh he spent
he apparently has not called any other
leaders
um he's generally looked as though he's
a little bit
rash and unconcerned so it does look as
though his focus is uniquely on the
domestic situation um and again i think
americans are very it's it's difficult
to try and explain the american psyche
because i think they kind of swing
between
uh historically they swing between being
far too eager to involve themselves in
world affairs and and too reluctant and
you saw after afghanistan sorry you saw
after vietnam
uh and saigon which everyone's been
talking about this week that american
people are very keen to sort of just
wash their hands of it
move on
not exactly pretend it never happened
but just move on and look forward and i
think biden may be more in tune with the
american mood than a lot of the media
are and i do understand what ben's
saying that uh that there is a change in
the polls at the moment but it would be
hardly it would be pretty surprising if
there wasn't given the barrage of
negative headlines that's going on i
think yeah i mean i think there's the
key thing there's another element here
freddie which is i think that americans
don't like losing
regardless of the rights and wrongs of
it so i mean you know seeing seeing
people being lifted out of um embassies
and on the back of chinooks with raging
mobs outside and all that type of thing
is obviously that that isn't good but
you're right that america is withdrawing
for you know is for most americans they
want that they liked us you know america
first
uh with donald trump and this in some
ways is an element of continuation of
that
they don't like losing they also don't
like never winning which i think has
been something that's defined american
policy for
for too many decades now
so ben what do you think could change
the possibility you mentioned a terror
attack back home but but also despite
the sweet talk from the taliban about uh
supporting women's rights to a degree
and we're starting to see or hear
reports at least that things might not
be as rosy as they suggest
people being tarred in kabul uh women
pleading to get out because they say the
taliban are after them so do you think
there are uh i suppose uh there's a
situation where uh chaotic scene in
afghanistan and the taliban uh bringing
in certain uh treatment of minorities
could change the
american audience reaction or do you
think it really has to be something more
on home soil
i fear it would have to be more
domestically affecting america or
americans than actually what's
unfortunately going on in terms of human
rights and misogyny inside afghanistan
to be quite honest
uh so you know
let's wait and see but
i think for many americans they've been
there a long time they've lost thousands
of lives um
you know they haven't been able to
they've invested they've spent trillions
uh the current zeitgeist is to is to you
know is to pull back and of course focus
on china and russia and freddie how is
this landing within the democratic party
because ultimately with the democrats uh
you have seen some i think uh natural
supporters of joe biden horrified um
saying that this is out the trump
playbook
so is this going to damage him
internally even if not when it comes to
the mass audience
i think it will certainly divide them
internally i mean if you look at the
sort of the if you like pro-israeli side
of of the democratic party they're
certainly anxious about the way
geopolitics is moving
in the region
however i also think that
people within the biden administration
spot the political opportunity that this
presents in the midterms and that's that
it splits
a slightly strange coalition that formed
in the trump years between
a sort of anti-right anti-war voter base
on the right and a very hawkish
pro-interventionist strand within the
republican party so
trump was successful through mike pompeo
his secretary of state he was successful
in in wooing the sort of people who
wanted to tear up the deal with iran who
wanted to rattle their sabers at iran
and north korea but he managed to not
get involved in a war at the same time
he was successful in appealing to people
who wanted to end the wars in
afghanistan and iraq but he never
actually really ended them
by going a little bit further by
actually ending this war in afghanistan
biden has sort of exposed a lot of
kind of semi-trumpist republicans as
being slightly fraudulent you you've
heard a lot of people in recent days who
just a year ago were saying we've got to
do whatever it takes to end the endless
wars now criticizing biden for doing
exactly that he's he's exposed a risk in
the republican party and and that could
present some opportunities for democrats
and and finally it's just it's fair to
say that but the majority of both
democrat voters and republican voters
say they support ultimately leaving
afghanistan so
not perhaps in this way but that's what
they support
so ben do you think actually in a way
this could put the republicans in a
tough position
yeah absolutely because what are they
what are they now going to say he's now
done the thing that donald trump started
oh oh dear we don't like it i mean no so
i we don't we i don't think it's going
to give him you know a lot of he's not
going to lose sleep over the republican
position or or where they might now go
the only thing i'd add is is the
incompetence factor if
because biden's starting to look
slightly incompetent on other fronts if
you look at inflation if you look at the
border
if there's a sort of general sense that
biden doesn't know what he's doing and
that he's making a mess of everything
that could start to hurt him but but
ben's absolutely right in terms of the
principles at the moment
uh the polls would suggest the public
are on his side
and his yes it's very different than
carter in you know in in 79 or around or
hostages or anything like that at the
moment
and just finally i wanted to uh speak to
you very briefly about the special
relationship uh freddie we have a
situation where today
um in the commons chamber you had uh
tory mps questioning the uk's reliance
on the us uh criticizing the fact that
ultimately once the us makes a decision
at the moment the uk seems to have to
fall into line even if they disagree um
what do you think is happening with the
relationship between biden and boris
do you think that we are seeing a weaker
relationship than previously or is it
beyond that
i don't think there's a lot of
communication between the two
administrations on key points on um
on what we've seen in parliament today i
i'd like to make a quite boringly
cynical point that i just think cameras
in parliament are a bad idea because we
saw this with hillary ben
and syria
uh and
the whole uh
frame media framing of every
parliamentary debate about foreign
affairs becomes about so the one big
speech
uh where some politician gets a sort of
wobbly lip says something emotional gets
a bit passionate maybe churchillian
and everybody says wasn't this
this defines this is what being a
parliamentarian is all about i don't
think it is i think being a
parliamentarian is about uh trying to
sort of decide what the british
government should do not
uh performing for social media
ben
um well i mean people whatever they say
they they like the performative stuff
going on in parliament and it it brings
it to life what we have seen is the
public and might the british public are
much more critical of america than
clearly the american public and in fact
by some margin say that it was you know
we say it was wrong for the americans to
leave uh and i guess and reflecting to a
certain extent the way we feel beholden
to them but again the british public
still really value the special
relationship and all of the heritage
history and things that it symbolizes so
again i don't i don't think any the
price of fish hasn't really changed on
that yet it's just a statement of fact
really what has happened i've got to add
though i think it is i mean i don't want
to sound like a self-hating brit i'm not
but it's quite easy for us to to talk
about what america should do in
afghanistan we haven't really done
anything afghanistan for 10 years it's
not really our problem anymore would you
not agree with that ben
i think i mean i think yes but we've
we've lost over we've lost over 450
lives in afghanistan we've had troops
there yes not as many as america etc so
i think you know again and the british
remain incredibly proud of our armed
forces they're you know they're you can
see that people want the veterans to be
treated fairly and there is that same
sort of general sense of what was it you
know why did we do that what was it all
for
uh so the british want to see um us
getting involved in humanitarian aid
most people want to see
us taking lots of refugees only 18 of
people in britain despite often being
anti-immigrant generally only 18 say
they don't want any afghans coming here
at all and for everybody else the
majority say if they've worked with us
we need to we need to look after them
now and step in we aren't you know we
aren't particularly keen on more
military action it clearly hasn't worked
very much but you know we want britain
to be engaged and that's you know that's
the path the government will now have to
tread i guess in that you know and and i
think it's a really interesting
challenge with america withdrawing it's
a big reminder to europe uh
with all without britain that it needs
to step up to the plate on some of this
stuff is america you know we need a
global policeman of some kind
potentially
and if america is not going to do as
much of it what is europe going to do
and i think that's another thing that
will be raised from all of this
freddie ben thank you for joining us
[Music]
you